[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we've talked a lot about college
football
and you know the playoffs now we have
the bowl games who can play
south carolina's got two wins they're
playing in a bowl game army is nine and
two
they're not playing in a bowl game and
their head coach jeff monken uh joins us
on the program uh coach thanks for
joining us
so explain this to me and how you
explained it to your kids
they're not playing in a bowl game well
first i got tv
can i give you an autograph story
because i love your autograph story sure
sure so i was a autographed seeker as a
kid
like you go to the ball games hang out
along the third base line of the first
baseline by the dugouts
so i want to tell you two stories about
autographs one was uh
j.r richards so the pitcher for the
astros got an autograph
before he had a stroke and after he had
a stroke i thought that was pretty cool
he's a great pitcher admired him uh and
his and his uh
and his career but my favorite autograph
was from don
sutton now he wasn't my favorite player
growing up
but kind of like you uh i had a little
conversation with don
on the third baseline out out in right
field
at the astrodome when i was about 12
years old
and uh he's coming along and dotson's a
great pitcher and
and i said oh mr sudden can i have your
autograph
and uh he comes over and he said
you know you gotta say please he said
you know
manners always manners always counts and
uh
i said i'm sorry i i uh i'm just so
excited to get you autograph i
i got good manners i just i i was just
so excited to get you autographed
i'm sorry i yelled at you and he said
don't convince me show me
and i've never forgotten that he said
that
and i still use that today i've used it
for my entire career
when a guy talks about doing something
and i'm going to do this so i'm going to
do that or i'm going to do better i say
don't convince me show me and i
and i've shared with them where i got
that that quote so i got don
don sutton to thank for that quote but
uh getting to uh
to our bowl game and and uh you know
we've had a great year i'm so proud of
our guys we we've had uh
two very emotional weeks playing the
army navy game and
coming right back to play for the
commander-in-chief's trophy
this past saturday here at west point
against air force and
our guys uh just battled and did a great
job and we were really looking forward
to the opportunity playing the
postseason we've been set up to play in
the independence bowl for
for over a year and and uh and have been
looking forward to that
like everybody the reward of playing in
the postseason in college football and
as the day went along yesterday and we
realized that
we were kind of getting pushed out and i
understand why and i'm not mad at the
system
it's it's a system that's created lots
and lots of opportunities for
for teams to play uh is the same system
that really kept us from
from having a guarantee yesterday but uh
there's a lot of teams that
haven't have had a chance to play and
i'm i'm not mad at the two win teams the
three win teams that are playing i
in fact i commend them that they are
taking the opportunity
to play this great game what i'm
disappointed is the teams that had a
chance to play
clamored for the opportunity to play
this fall
are now deciding they don't want to play
i don't understand it
and we've got a team who is deserving
of playing in a bowl game uh they're a
great they're a great
team they're not the most talented team
in the country not the most talented
team i've coached but they're the best
team i've coached
and and they're a group of young men who
have made a pledge a commitment to serve
this nation
and we've got seniors who have earned
the opportunity to play in a bowl game
who are in tears last night
six months from now they're gonna
they're gonna take a pledge to serve in
the united states army
and ultimately are willing to pay the
ultimate price
for us to enjoy the freedoms we have and
the way of life that we enjoy
to play this game and to have the right
to say
yes i want a player no i don't want to
play but when there's a team like that
that is uniquely positioned to represent
the 1.3 million men and women who serve
on active duty our united states army
they deserve the opportunity to not just
play for themselves but to
represent those men and women and and i
hear all that we've been through that
it's always for all this team has been
through this year we're just
deciding to opt out well i challenge
for all that our soldiers have been
through and all that their families have
been through
for families who have had loved ones
deployed for a year or more
and been away from their families that
will spend this holiday season away from
their families
we we owe it to them to represent them
and uh and we just we want the
opportunity to do that
we're hoping that there'll some way
somehow there'll be a chance but
i talked to our guys about it i told
them to told the truth
on how it got to this point uh
they were obviously disappointed but
what they said was coach
if if we got a chance then let us
continue to prepare
and and get ready and and that's that's
what we've done all year we've just
prepared we're not planned uh we had
a 12 game schedule in july and we played
three of those original teams but still
managed to play 11 games we we've
prepared
not planned and it's what it's what an
infantry unit does
they prepare they don't plan they don't
know where the battle's coming they
don't know what the weather's going to
be they don't know how many bad guys are
going to be on the other side
what their firepower is but but they're
going to be prepared
and our our our country can be proud to
know that we've got soldiers out there
that are protecting our freedoms and our
way of life
and that we've got football players who
are are playing on this team that have
made that same commitment so
uh i i our guys are just a great bunch
of guys so we're gonna stay here for the
next few days we're gonna figure out
if we get a chance to play and and see
what comes of it
how important is it for the coach at the
academy to have been
through the academy to understand what
these i can't these men and women go
through
to to kind of understand what their
schedule is their life is
what happens after they graduate get
deployed like there's
there's a whole lot that goes into this
coach that it's not just
come on in and play some football for me
it is
and uh it's important that we all
understand that and embrace that
and it's one of the things i love about
west point i've uh
i've had the opportunity to serve as a
coach at two of our service academies
and it's uh
it's been a great pleasure my my career
to be able to do that to serve these
young men and women
who are going to serve our nation and i
didn't go to school here
but i'm proud to represent our united
states army in this way and to serve in
this way to develop the leaders of
character that our army
needs and deserves to uh to lead our
soldiers and
and i i understand this place and i i
embrace what we are as an institution
and uh and i know our players realize
that about me
that that though i didn't experience
this that i understand their life and
their commitment
and and when we do bring a young man in
here it's not just all about football
but that's what makes them so special
but also you it's one thing to say
goodbye to a senior
like it this is different when you say
goodbye to your seniors
you don't know what's going to happen to
them it's not like hey i'll keep an eye
on you
in the nfl or you know you get a job as
an accountant somewhere
you're saying goodbye to men who
you might be saying goodbye to they may
they may have to pay the ultimate price
but they've they've made that choice
and they've made that commitment and you
know
all of us should be incredibly thankful
for every man woman
uh in this nation that that takes that
pledge
and there are millions of americans who
have taken
that pledge and and currently serve and
those that will take that pledge and
and our guys do too and uh you know
our guys go into all walks of life they
go into all all different kinds of jobs
in the army
um they don't all have the same job but
they've all made the same commitment
and uh and i'm really proud of them and
i just i would love to
to see them be rewarded with this
opportunity of a bowl and they
desperately want to play
and hopefully we can give even more
publicity to this and we appreciate you
coming on and
and we're happy to be able to help
facilitate this so they do get a chance
and maybe there's a school that opts out
that they can't play and you guys slide
in you guys have certainly been ready to
play anybody
anywhere and i brought this up when
you'll get
people who will say well you know these
teams that aren't in the power five
conferences they can't really play with
the big boys and i always bring up
when army went to oklahoma a couple of
years ago
and they had kyler murray and you took
him into overtime
so i don't i i don't want to hear oh you
know those
uh smaller schools can't stick with the
big guys i don't know how you did it
that day
but you did it well
this team in the last three years has
taken two top ten teams to overtime
overtime and double overtime double
overtime at michigan a year ago
and uh and i assure you that that it
wasn't because of
of our talent uh we got some talented
guys we got some good football players
but our guys just play really hard they
play they play together
they care deeply for each other there's
a sense of brotherhood in this program
that's unlike any team i've ever been a
part of and and uh
and it's it's because of the shared
experience that they'll have after they
graduate
that that that creates a bond in this
team
and uh i you know we didn't win either
of those games
so i guess the they're right we just we
weren't able to
to finish the job but we've won some
power five games here since i've been
here as the head coach and
and uh we're gonna have a chance to play
some more and hopefully we'll be able to
to come away with some victories but
just the spirit of this team and
and what they mean to this country uh i
think it's great for college football i
think it's
obviously great for our our players but
uh but for those men and women that we
represent
i think it's important that we we we
play and and uh and not just
say hey we're gonna opt out well you
can't give up i mean that's
that's who you that's who you are and uh
you know hopefully i'll get a chance to
get up there next season i i
i appreciate the invitation that i got
for the army navy game i got a
compromised immune system and
uh probably the last person who should
be traveling anywhere but that game
means that much to me
that i i wanted to be there to
experience it so congratulations on the
season
and uh hopefully there's somebody
listening who says you're right
that army should be playing in a bowl
game this year coach so
thank you and uh our best to you same to
you thanks a lot we'll look forward to
seeing you at the army navy game next
year
all right coach munken yeah we're ready
to go
after that speech damn now i'm really
mad
that army's not playing